Thank you for taking up your lunch hour.
Death.
So I wanted to start with,
um,
how many people in the audience,
a vegetarian?
A couple,
if anyone in the audience,
he's a Vegan.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I did that as well.
I found it really tough anyway.
Um,
okay,
great.
And who if,
um,
thinks they ought to be Vegan or vegetarian,
but you can't resist when they have something nice on in the restaurant or you
know,
you know,
a keys if you go to your granny to Sunday roast.
Um,
so you sort of slightly British about it and they want,
yeah.
So that was me.
I,
um,
I was working as,
an environment correspondent on the Daily Telegraph newspaper.
So as interviewing climate change scientists all the time and writing about
climate change.
And I knew that emissions from livestock makeup more than all the transport and
the world put together.
And I knew that one of the easiest things I could do with to give up eating
meat.
Um,
I also knew all the other threats.
I didn't have any of you have seen Cowspiracy but you know,
um,
obviously,
uh,
growing and animal takes more water.
Uh,
you might clear forests,
there's all the fossil fuels in growing the feed for the animal.
Um,
and you know,
at the far end of the scale,
you can talk about it driving species extinctions,
ocean dead zones.
And again,
I thought,
well,
you know,
either think I could do with a go vegetarian,
but I'm a farmer's daughter and I'd go home and I try and be vegetarian and my
granny or my dad would say,
well,
this is Bennison from the hill.
You know,
these animals are cute eating all the trees.
What's wrong with eating this?
Or,
you know,
it's 40 range,
um,
capital.
You can see them out in the field bad.
They don't look miserable to me.
So I thought,
okay,
um,
I'm going to do something quite extreme.
I'm going to only eat animals.
Um,
I kill myself.
So these are the,
um,
are getting a little ahead of myself here,
but all the other benefits of agriculture,
I thought to my,
um,
obviously I could see from my own family,
uh,
farming families who've,
um,
make their money out of raising meat,
but they also sustain the countryside.
When you think about dry stone walls and what you see when you go on holidays to
the countryside,
carbon storage,
you know,
past delays are actually just as good at throwing carbon as rain forests,
um,
waste.
Um,
if animals are being killed,
why not eat them?
So I decided to be an ethical carnival,
which is to me,
to only animals.
I killed myself because then I thought I can truly justify it.
So I started quite slowly because honestly it was a bit of a scary idea and I
went oyster shucking.
Um,
and I knew that how many of you eat oysters?
but,
uh,
they grow all around the British coast and they're actually quite a sustainable
meat to eat because when oysters feed,
they're filtering the water and a lot of the oysters around the British case or
an invasive species.
So we want to get rid of them anyway.
So that was quite an easy start.
In fact,
I guess quite a few of you been to California and,
uh,
there's people out who called themselves Austra vegans.
So they only eat mussels and oysters because they think that,
uh,
they don't feel pain because,
you know,
they don't have the nerve endings for it.
And,
uh,
by farming them,
you're actually improving the environment.
So it's the one meet the valley only in California.
Um,
and then there was fishing as well.
And fishing was where I really started to think about my connection to the
environment because,
you know,
you have to stand on a riverbank or a guard,
see for a long time and it really forces you to think about what's happening in
the environment around you.
You know,
you have to choose a fly,
you have to be very quiet.
Uh,
you have to understand what the,
what the fish are feeding out on and that time of year.
So it's a w it started me thinking,
you know,
about my connection as a,
as a sort of hunter gatherer.
Um,
but of course I also had to be realistic because that's not how most of us get
our fish.
We get it from the seas.
And,
um,
there's a wonderful book called the end of the line,
which I read and um,
and I went out on a fishing boat and it's quite a brutal,
um,
industry fishing,
you know,
the animals usually die in the hold and,
um,
and it's also got to having a real impact on the environment.
I'm sure many of you know the statistics from drudging.
Um,
so I tried to think about is are they sustainable ways to eat fish.
And one of the biggest things I found having gone to fish markets as we only
five species,
which is ridiculous,
and lots of those species are actually under threat.
I wouldn't,
I mean card of our own coast,
I've still not a healthy population because we so overfish them.
So why not try,
um,
I'm sure Ben knows will be different species but curly and different species.
So that was an ethical way I felt around fishing.
Another,
um,
option if farmed fish,
which obviously takes the pressure off wild fish.
So I went to a salmon farm and salmon farming as cat.
A really,
um,
the caused a lot of damage in the past.
Um,
fee life live on the salmon and that passes to the wild population and their
said wild fish from,
um,
other places around the world.
Mophie anchovies from places like Peru.
And that has an impact on ocean ecosystems that it is something I think is
improving.
And when I went to visit those places,
um,
I genuinely found people and the,
and the West highlands of Scotland who said that it was,
uh,
providing employment in really remote areas,
but they could do so much to improve how it's done and a close circulation.
So,
um,
the,
this,
the sewage from the fish isn't going into the oceans and I'd urge you to look up
front before the,
um,
with,
with wild fish marine stewardship council.
But then now there's an aquaculture stewardship council.
So hopefully if we put pressure on the organizations,
we can get sustainable farm fish as well.
But it's not straightforward.
Nothing is.
So that was all quite easy,
but I had to move on to,
um,
uh,
other animals to eat.
And the first thing I shot with a rabbit,
and that was quite
upsetting because you have to take responsibility.
Um,
it,
but I never really got over that,
but that was a lot of the motivation in writing the book.
And then when you eat animals,
an animal dies.
And taking that on,
uh,
really upset me.
I cried the gamekeeper I was with cried and that's really where the book begins.
Um,
but in the Fed,
the big question is why did I carry on doing it?
But I looked at the people like the gamekeeper I was with who go out and she
animals to eat themselves and they had a much greater understanding of many,
uh,
of the countryside and many conservationists I knew and I wanted to learn from
them and I wanted to continue the journey.
So I did and I got a little bit better at it.
So I learned,
learnt,
shoot with a rifle,
um,
and to do it as cleanly and quickly as I possibly could.
Um,
a squirrel,
which is a good example of where,
um,
they're,
they're being controlled anyway to help the red squirrel population comeback.
So I fed my girlfriend squirrel satay and they enjoyed it very much.
Um,
and shotguns shooting if the other,
um,
uh,
type of shooting.
It's different from using a rifle,
very challenging.
Um,
I did shoot a pheasant,
um,
obviously in Britain that has different implications because,
it's very mixed up with land ownership and class people only traditionally do it
who,
um,
have the money and live in the countryside.
And um,
it kind of exposed me.
But I wanted to go into that cause I think it's,
um,
I think it's really interesting and two thirds of our farmland is managed for
game birds in this country.
So what effect is that having on the countryside?
And my argument is there a good and bad shoot?
So let's talk about it openly rather than saying they're all bad.
Um,
and I like to eat forever,
I'm afraid,
but the best way Tepe hasn't roadkill.
So,
um,
and there's lots of,
of them on the road at certain time of year.
So I also learn how identifier to identify roadkill safely,
which is,
people often ask me about the legal implications and you have to take
responsibility for yourselves people,
but you can do it.
And the ultimate thing I killed with this stack with my father and that was
quite an emotional journey because my dad's hunted all his life and it's
something I'd,
my brother's done but I'd never done.
And um,
I had sort of come to a realization of why I was doing it because I had to
question was I doing this to impress my dad?
But by the time I got to that stage,
um,
I was doing it for myself because only you can take responsibility.
You have to be control of yourself and what you're doing.
And um,
and,
and that was an amazing experience.
It really taught me a lot and gave me great respect for the animal.
And it took me quite a long time to eat it with all my friends and family.
I tend to share all the meat I ate.
Um,
but all this is,
I'm very nice talking about going out and hunting and fishing and something
that,
uh,
requires a lot of time and energy.
Um,
you could argue it's something you need to be quite privileged,
but I mean you can do it.
Anyone can do it if you put the time and energy into it.
But most of us are eating meat.
That's obviously farms.
And I wanted it to look at that as well cause that's where most of the
environmental impact is of course.
And in Britain reach 1 billion farm animals a year.
So I wanted to find out how they're raised chickens with a good start because in
this country,
that's what we're eating the most of,
uh,
competitive.
Uh,
the 50s where you might have it once a week.
When are eating chicken three times a week?
Um,
2.2 million chickens a day.
but have you ever seen any chickens in the countryside?
Where are these chicken's been raised?
So I went to a chicken farm and saw them,
uh,
indoors.
They usually raised,
uh,
tens of thousands in a barn and,
they are gassed when they're slaughtered.
And the Ma,
the big realization with chickens is,
you know,
they're being raised on such a scale.
Uh,
they,
it's too dense.
You know,
the animals,
the animals can't move around easily.
They've been so bred to have big breasts that they collapse on their legs.
Um,
but there were very small things you can do.
I looked at RSPC assured checkins and they're still indoors,
but at least they have daylight and readings roam around.
So,
um,
there are things that you can do quite easily.
That's me in a,
um,
in a chicken farm.
Um,
uh,
I also looked at pigs,
I went to Denmark,
which is where we get most of our port from in this country.
And again,
it was very intensive and I found pigs more difficult,
cause I would argue that chickens indoors can be quite happy.
But pigs,
when you see pigs out doors,
they just love to root in the ground.
And I like feel that,
and that's from my pork to come from that and it.
But in Denmark,
they do it on a massive scale and they have,
um,
a slaughterhouse with glass walls where you can see it happening.
Um,
which was,
uh,
quite interesting.
I wouldn't,
I would argue that it doesn't tell you the whole story,
but if I'm quite an interesting insight into how other cultures are more about
where their meat comes from.
Um,
and I went into avatars of course,
because that was a big question I was trying to ask,
you know,
like where does our meat come from?
And again,
I found it very upsetting initially,
but I wanted to continue to try and understand because the people who were doing
it,
I felt deserve my respect.
I think if you're going to eat meat,
you should respect that people will do it on your behalf or not meet,
need to tool.
Um,
and I also went and visited a lot of farmers and these people weren't earning a
lot of money and raising really good meat,
you know,
beautiful.
This is,
um,
a man called rarely puzey and he's,
he's,
um,
raising sheep on national trust land and it's on a Sussex.
It's Downlands.
Downlands.
And there are flowers and birds that survive in that farmland as it's managed.
And the consequence of that is the sheep.
So why not eat them and you know,
um,
uh,
keep that cycle going.
So,
I mean,
that was the other reason I continued to do it because I respected those farmers
and wanted to understand,
uh,
their business,
not dismiss them.
And I did some home slaughter as well,
which was pretty intense.
And I learned about butchery.
Um,
I was following everything all the way through.
so,
um,
again,
having,
having said all that,
you know,
people firth question as well,
that's all very well,
but how do I judge where my meat comes from and that our labels you can look out
for?
I always quite cautious because labels can change and I think you can't rely on,
there's probably something that Google talk about a lot is you can't rely on a
corporation to make your decisions for you.
It's about your education,
which is what I'm trying to do through my book is to give you all the
information so you can make the best decisions.
But there's definitely a few that,
uh,
I've already mentioned MFE fish rfpc assured,
which is just a little bit more expensive,
but,
um,
ensures better welfare and of course organic.
And there's a new one called pasture fed,
which means they've been kept out doors and only fed on pasture,
which is a new one and it's pretty good.
Um,
or just the last,
or don't be evil.
I was thinking of the Google,
um,
tagline because I kind of think if you are concerned about the environment,
like eating less meat is just one of the easiest things you can do.
And a lot of the charities have written reports on that and I think they keep it
quite quiet because they don't want to theme like they're lecturing people.
Um,
but it is a fact.
It really helps reduce your carbon footprint and also it's good for your health.
You know,
too much red meat is bad for you.
So,
um,
and this is what I,
I actually ate much less meat than the average person.
They people think,
uh,
you know,
the ethical kind of warmer food eating those meet that actually compared to most
people.
I am a lot less me doing it myself.
Um,
and um,
I tried out all the alternatives including insects.
Oh,
possum around in a minute.
Um,
but there are other,
um,
in vitro meets whether growing meat from stem cells,
which freaks me out past me.
Um,
it's a bit weird,
but,
um,
lots of,
vegans a welcome it and,
and,
and say they would eat burgers from meat grown in a test tube and plant protein,
which is something that's huge in silicon valley.
Lots of,
uh,
well Google,
I know we're looking into,
but also,
uh,
I think someone from Twitter,
um,
impossible foods beyond meat and they're all trying to find plant based
alternatives,
which I think,
um,
is,
is likely to be the future.
So,
uh,
I do think that we will be eating less meat in the future.
And I just think the ethical carnival,
if about the philosophical side of it,
that people don't often consider,
you know,
that eating animals obviously has an impact.
The animals are raised and killed on our behalf.
So I hope it gives people a better understanding of that side of it.
And,
uh,
I'll pass around some insects and we'll do some questions.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Um,
so I've got a few questions initially.
there's more awareness now around how animals are kept,
as you touched on yeah.
And the environmental impact of eating meat.
So as a result,
people are turning to a Vegan Diet,
what do you think the implications would be of the whole population?
Won't be good.
Um,
do you think it's a sustainable way of life for humans and for the investment?
Well,
there have been studies done.
I looked into,
into that and,
uh,
there was one done a,
um,
it was published in an actual proceedings of science,
last year and it found that it would reduce if everyone went vegan.
It would reduce carbon emissions by half compared to compared to 2005 by 2050.
Um,
but,
but I personally don't think that's realistic and,
um,
it's certainly not in the short term anyway.
And there's been other studies that found that,
um,
if just a third,
uh,
if if people ate less meat,
then it would have a similar impact over time.
And if you think about it,
if you have,
if you asked everyone to go Vegan,
I think you'd have quite small percentage of the population,
but if you ask people to eat less meat,
I think you're talking,
uh,
did the majority of the population in the future and that can have a much bigger
impact.
And you,
and I do think you'd lose a lot.
Um,
because a lot of our agriculture is based on a animal inputs,
you know,
think about pigs,
they give the waste,
we feed them waste.
Um,
and we have lots of cultural associations with the meat,
meat,
Michelle,
you wouldn't necessarily want to name.
So I think less meat is a better one than just everyone going to be even,
yeah.
The Sunday roast for example.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
of all the meat substitutes available,
and those in the,
again that you touched on,
which ones do you think will be the most popular?
Um,
and the ones most adopted by the population and then the most sustainable as
well.
Um,
I think plant proteins because,
um,
a lot of,
uh,
our lifestyles now we demoed a lot of processed meat,
but I think what people are really uncomfortable with cheap meat and that's
processed meat.
And I think that that,
um,
alternatives like,
uh,
impossible beyond meat,
chicken strips and things like that are really growing.
And I think that will,
that's the thing that will really take off in the future because the technology
is improving to make it taste better.
Um,
and in terms of sustainability,
people often are,
do you know well that still soy protein and stuff like that.
So,
um,
but those companies,
I think the people who are buying those things are demanding that it comes from
a sustainable source and it's still more sustainable than feeding the soil to,
to animals.
So I think that we'll see a great growth in that area.
What do you see people eating,
putting in five years time?
What do you think the challenges are going to be around?
We educating the public so they change their
happy eating less than better meat because,
uh,
I'm not the only one talking about it like Jamie Oliver.
He within still like really powerful celebrity chefs.
But I think the big challenge is time because people don't,
I can talk about,
hey,
why don't you go to a butcher and try new cuts of meat or try awful.
But that's a lot of work for people with busy lives.
So I think it's about putting the time and possibly the money towards those
better cuts of meat.
And that is important because the farmers that I talked about in my talk or
allowing on people to carry on buying meat,
red meat and that's reducing as well as processed meat.
Um,
and I don't think we should,
uh,
sometimes if statistic people eating less meat,
it's because they're just eating less from butches and stuff.
And I think it'd be,
uh,
if people are gonna eat meat,
that kind of stuff they should get is from farmers birch.
And the other challenge is gender variance.
We can see from the audience here,
uh,
women are quite interested in it.
And then,
oh and I were talking about in the book,
I sort of dismiss that and say,
Hey,
you know,
it doesn't mean you're less macho.
And I thought about it and I thought,
um,
if you go to a barbecue in London and a guy comes along with Veggie Burgers,
no one would raise an eyebrow.
But a lot of pieces in Britain they would be pasted.
So I think that that needs questioning cause that's a little bit ridiculous
because there's a lot of guys love me and it makes them feel good but it doesn't
make them more match it.
That's ridiculous.
So we probably need to challenge that.
And the other thing in five years time,
I think we maybe feel a little bit of a,
just sort of thinking about how things go.
You generally go in cycles and you know,
clean eating and veganism is so popular now,
but I feel like it will maybe settle down to,
um,
into incorporating some of those habits into how we eat rather than saying
people should go vegan and eat clean.
Because I don't think that works for a lot of people.
But I think a lot of messages from that movement will come into everyday eating
more.
So it'd be easier to eat less meat and still have a good time.
Great.
Thank you so much.
Not at all.
Anyone have any other questions?
Okay,
cool.
Of course.
[inaudible] thank you for coming to,
what was the weirdest thing you ate?
So your standards a weird
oh yeah.
Okay.
That's,
I mean,
loads of really weird things.
Say the squirrel was quite weird,
me and sex.
But um,
when I caught,
I caught a fresh card and I eat their egg sacks,
which is row and it was amazing.
It was the best thing I've eaten cause it's like having ass.
But that is quite weird to have fresh called ro.
And I ate the stag heart,
uh,
in esteem and I,
which was really delicious and the liver and the kidneys,
which was so nice.
Yeah.
And that was,
um,
yeah,
that was something you mentioned this,
that,
yeah.
You said you went with,
your dad actually killed this tag.
You,
you're done me,
of course.
To be creepy.
How did you kill this time?
Cool.
Okay.
Yeah.
But we,
the book for the full,
yeah.
Yeah.
The [inaudible],
um,
with a,
with a powerful rifle.
Where in London do you think is a place where we can find the,
like the fish that are outside of those five species,
because I actually,
I'm not the kit,
but in believes in market with a five
in the morning.
But if you go down spending skate,
you will see tens of species of fish and you'll just be that I had no idea this
existed.
And it's,
it doesn't,
it doesn't smell of fish either cause it all fresh and uh,
well not too bad.
It less than you think it would be.
And there's just,
it's mind blowing.
Like,
you know,
you didn't know what a haddock or cod looks like.
Well,
I didn't until I went to a fish market.
And then you see,
hey,
can ling and monkfish and like on that picture,
the ugliest,
ugliest,
strangers fish.
So it's quite,
um,
it's quite amazing,
quite joyful to see the,
to feed the variety.
And,
and then there are restaurants which do,
um,
which do you cook those fish,
which was,
I can't,
I can't think of one.
Sorry.
I don't live in London.
Do you know,
learn this.
Yeah.
And last but not least,
if one is too hard,
you could give me three.
What are your three or your favorite food in the world?
The ospreys,
but it'd be,
you won't meet
Raspberries,
raspberries.
There's some in the entrance
by the way.
My nephews,
nieces always ask me that question.
Any other questions?
Hi.
I'm just curious.
Like how are you continuing with it now?
Preston?
And I said at the end of the book,
um,
I'm stopping it now.
Um,
and largely because I want people to be able to pick up the book in 10 years'
time and it still be genuine,
you know?
Um,
so I wanted to do something that was sustainable for me.
So,
um,
I eat less.
I definitely last meet and when I started the whole project because I questioned
it a lot more.
Um,
but now actually the further I go,
that does recede.
And you do think about it less,
which is interesting itself because that's how I think you have to be honest.
That's how humans think,
you know,
you can watch a video and be really concerned about something and then six
months later when you're eating a burger,
you don't really think about it.
And I'm do that as well.
So it's receding,
but I eat less meat.
And,
um,
I,
I um,
um,
continuing to learn about a shooting and fishing and doing it myself because I
never wanted to do it as a one off.
I wanted to learn those skills and that takes longer than 18 months.
So I'm still doing that,
but not a huge amount because it takes a lot of money and time.
And,
um,
and I'm also trying to explore,
you know,
things like different fish species and different cuts of meat because I'm quite
greedy and I really enjoy that.
So,
yeah,
so I'm what I call,
I'm trying to be an ethical carnival.
What form?
Ethical carnival.
Yeah.
I was just wondering what your farming commonly thought of the book and they
read it and he loved it.
Yeah.
Habits or are they still really interesting people?
Um,
sometimes it makes me kind of cringe when people are like,
don't worry to weeds.
It's not like processed chicken or something.
And it kind of makes me cringe because I
find it difficult to tell other people what to eat even though the book is about
what you eat.
I'm just telling my story because otherwise you feel great,
you feel a bit didactic and finger wagging.
Um,
but really positive.
I thought they might feel like I was attacking them because a lot of them raised
meat.
Um,
but they were actually really open minded and welcomed it because most,
a lot of me in Britain is really high quality
and it would help farmers to talk about,
uh,
the quality and why,
why it should be appreciated and paid more.
Because in this country,
we struggle to,
um,
uh,
compete with processed meat from abroad anyway.
So,
yeah,
they loved it.
It's very nice.
Yeah.
I mean,
lots of people ask,
hey,
you know,
do you want to,
did you eat a bachelor fox or something
weird like that,
you know?
And I was like,
no,
why would I do that?
You know,
or,
you know,
I didn't do,
the scleral was unusual,
but I didn't know quite tasty and it was accessible,
but I wasn't going to push exhaust takeover where it needs for the sake of it.
And I,
and I really not interested in that and I'm not,
I'm not really interested in,
um,
like if I traveled to other countries where there are meet switch and our
country,
we'd find where like dove or who was,
I don't,
I really don't.
I feel like I understand cultural taboos and I feel them and that's fine.
I don't need to cost them.
So,
yeah,
I know.
Interesting thing that much.
Um,
firstly think when the news came out,
you were coming to see us.
I was so excited.
I said a couple of years,
but this really resonates for me because I went vegetarian two years ago and
this was sort of the principle that I wanted to take as well,
which is I believe that obviously,
you know,
people just eat meat,
they just get it in itself,
in packet.
They don't even tie it back to an animal dying.
So I wanted to actually follow that,
which is I will only eat meat,
I'll kill myself.
But I love animals so much.
I will cry at a cartoon land dying that legacy.
I haven't eaten meat because simply can't kill.
How,
how do you see the most effective way of getting the message across to the
masses?
Have you successfully transferred,
you know,
or changed any of your friends mindsets without maybe overstepping the
boundaries of scaring the hell out of them and made them watch sort of videos
and I have lost some friends over that and I realized that's the wrong way of
doing it.
So yeah.
How would you think is the most effective way to spread?
Interesting.
The reaction to this book?
A lot of,
I thought I'd get a lot of,
um,
uh,
pushback back from vegans.
People would be upset by it,
but Ashley have been not that much and I've actually had sometimes more
aggressive from people who really love me and do not want to know and want me to
shut up.
Um,
so,
um,
it's surprising who you can annoy.
Um,
uh,
I think it has to be really gradual.
I mean if you can sort of talk about nudge theory and make it positive.
So if you see salespeople,
you can't eat stuff,
then they shut down.
And um,
and I think the,
and if you say you have to be vegetarian or Vegan,
then I think they just shut down.
But I think if you tell them like,
oh my God,
if you tried this amazing new food that happens to be a plant protein,
or have you ever tried awful or have you tried meeting a butcher?
So I think through a series of positive messages rather than,
um,
set active,
but so much what you said was interesting,
cause I say I,
a lot of people say you should only animals.
If you've killed them yourself,
but I would argue lots of people that would be too much like you,
and that's unrealistic and ridiculous.
Anyway.
Um,
and I felt like,
I'm not sure I necessarily wanted to do that,
but I just felt my role as a writer and I had an opportunity to explore a
subject so people didn't have to
have any more questions.
Wonderful.
Thank you all so much for coming.